all right so I am pretty far in the game
here at this point should be oh because
you're in you're in the same zone I am
yeah yeah I'm pretty far I need to oh
let me I met do though I have to fight
this I have to attempt to fight this
shark this great what's that
great white he's you get a really cool
upgrade for killing him alright let's
see if I can do it they he was a little
tough so I might need to go play some
other stuff we you guys play Grand Theft
Auto next week on Friday um I'd be down
because I don't really know what else we
would play next week I think we could
probably we should probably check it and
see how it's doing yeah a week later if
I know what combat has its big update
and that might be but yeah but if it's
doing better I'm definitely down to hold
on this hammerheads given me this game
come to console today it's out today on
everything and this games out oh boy
I played the Xbox version of it and had
almost no issues outside of like an
overheating thing but close to GTA
switch games yeah GTA was kind of messed
up and we spent an hour trying to get it
to work yeah so we we eventually decided
to at least let you guys see something
right because we felt bad so we we
started up start man-eater a game that
came out today so we can try to salvage
this and ah this is bad I got two great
whites on me which is not what I want
know about God but yeah sorry about the
the misleading title that we just
switched you know if you want then you
can change the title well I can't that's
true if you want to go in I'm you're
getting so many slack message just
alright well I got that guy out of the
way so now I got it
where's that other boy yeah so if you
don't know what this game is you bet
it's basically like a like a revenge
story the story this is wild this
fisherman who does like a Discovery
Channel like television program killed
your mom and and and reach you out of
her belly as she was still pregnant with
you and then threw you into the water
after you got do you bite his arm off is
just to like get more and more powerful
that you can get singe and get revenge
on the man that killed your shark mom
the the as you put it earlier to me the
JRPG of storytelling tropes but applied
to recharge yeah it the bad guy killed
your parents so you have to go and get
revenge on yeah bone tale is that what I
got to do it yeah what upgrades do you
have I've got the bone body I'm all bone
in the boat okay I'm pure bone baby
so you haven't much of the like cutting
down the people right I've done some of
that I just said so here I can go into
my see I got a little hope you stay safe
and have fun yeah
thank you I got the bone teeth I got the
bio the bio electric teeth as well I
really like the bioelectric set but as
soon as I realized like I was doing the
higher level like boat boat stuff where
you got to kill the the dudes who come
in to hunt you realize that the that is
much better for messing up boats right
so I have yeah right now I have all
pretty much all bone I've advanced so
NAR which I don't use that much better
should swap that I have more health if
it is what made me realize I wanted to
do a hundred percent because it just
marks everything in a whole zone for you
it's great
I like insidious because it makes it
easier to get on the ground which is a
lot of fun maybe I'll put that on I kind
of wish it gave you like legs though
like it has in the picture yes I also
agree let's head over to do sapphire Bay
that's no no no we want ahead too with
sapphire it's golden shores that's the
one we want to go to it's really cool
how the different parts actually affect
your shark and in a lot of ways yeah if
you get the bioelectric set you actually
phase and turn into electricity when you
do your dodge and at stun stuff and then
you also have like an EMP blast that
comes out and hits things around you I
got but the stone one you have now lets
you like do a corkscrew spin that does
more damage to me yeah and I love the
idea of just corkscrew spinning it's
really good I get this thing here come
on the other one too is I got the UH
like you just got the the stone tail and
that makes it so that you have like like
harder hit when you do your tail swipe
hold on hold on I see him I see a guy
but the electric one lets you like shoot
electricity yeah yeah is the good [ __ ]
oh we finally got the fact that you
can't big old a group of people oh I
love that you can just you can come up
on the straw and jump around and eat
people it's a really satisfying
did you uh did you change the stream
name by the way I see a couple people
mentioning cheat if you don't mind doing
that just so that no one's confused for
the next we go yeah I could just say it
yeah GTA was broke
oh we felt bad and we decided to play a
game that came out today yeah we figured
that you'd actually have something to
look at
see mr. Conlon reminds me of Madagascar
- oh yeah we're sorry if we came in
expecting GTA it it was our planning our
intention and we'll probably come back
to it when it's working again but it's
it's in a way right now
yeah it's given us a lot of trouble GTA
v hello marry me - I'm I'm dead serious
when I say this - like this game really
surprised me
me too I thought it was just gonna be
like it kind of like almost silly just
ah you're eating people that's cool I
guess
like there's smart writing that's clever
and funny art writing I would also say
it's a game that that doesn't have the
best impression gameplay wise I think
it's a little it honestly felt a little
dry at first but you can't do that much
with the combat like when you're when
you're a little baby a little puppet
shark yeah but once the game gets going
it it gets a lot better I also
appreciate just the sense of growth that
you get so you're like not just because
you physically get bigger but because
you'll be like when you're in the the
first level as a baby shark and you're
fighting against or dodging alligators
because they'll tear you apart in like
two hits yep it eventually going back
there is like a slightly bigger shark
and just being able to tear them apart
it's really satisfying I don't know if
I'd go so far as a game of the year what
do you know it's like a really it's it
feels like that really good like middle
tier game you know but you don't see
that much anymore like it's just it
feels really good and it's a it's a
funny world in this case yeah
okay technically you can sort of play as
a shark in GTA which I feel like could
feel like the story is kind of sad you
feel bad for the shark yeah they don't
like an interesting job of uh like at
first I thought that the main antagonist
was just a really gross guy who wants to
kill fish because they're like I'm doing
whatever but as I got I got further on
I'm like oh there's actual kind of like
weirdness to these characters to these
characters that are also super OneNote
but also you eat people
yeah look I ain't Abe I didn't expect
eighty percent of what I got yeah it's
kind of all over the place but I sort of
loved it it's a beautiful mess yeah
was he a family guy's sequel the jaws
bigger jaws it's a good bit there's that
game jaws unleashed this reminds me a
lot of that there are a lot of people
who are saying that this gives them like
a good kind of like this is almost like
a jaws only sequel to them it doesn't
feel like that for sure yeah you could
relate to a shark of all things sharks
aren't like bad things this that's also
a cool thing there's a lot of
educational value in this game sort of
this sometimes they give you like actual
cold hard facts about like fish in and
like water and sharks but then they'll
also like give me like goofy so about it
yeah the whole the whole game is
narrated by Chris Parnell who you might
know as Jerry from Rick and Morty or
Cyril from Archer yeah and he he's like
a like a planet Earth type of narrator
and I love like it like I say it like
it'll it'll give you like the fact but
then it'll come in with like a joke
anyway it'll it'll be like yeah the bull
shark is usually very docile and not
dangerous to humans until now that is
after like yeah I'm like okay cool now I
know that the bull shark was a more
docile breed a shark but also the game
acknowledge that I'm tearing people
apart I'm doing ridiculous spin tricks
on these boats a little bit sick how
cool I got a guy to show up yeah well
sharks are flippin rad they're so big it
just is just so nice
I've actually been trying to change the
title for a while now and for some
reason I can't login do you want me to
trying to it so you're the middle
playing so you shouldn't I'm just gonna
keep trying to like there I can I could
try and change it real quick yeah there
if you haven't like immediately handy go
for it but I do I am getting thrown
around in a loop some signing in then
it's putting me in unlike my actual
YouTube account and I don't want to be
there I want to switch this complex Auto
online but actually it's man-eater hello
what was that sport more slack messages
Chuck still the reason why I never swim
a beach there I mean most most attacks
most attacks from sharks happen in
shallow water by accident then they
don't go after they don't like eating
people
[Music]
could you see how my shark Edition give
me one sec I'm almost there
GA is broke so we decided to become a
shark yeah basically other boss fights
in this game yeah there are there's
there's you're about to fight one of the
human oh I already am I'm pretty sure oh
you're sure Adam there are human bosses
they're apex predator bosses for each of
the fish in the different zones there's
the main bad guy yeah they're they're
cool cool boss fights sure I was gonna
say with the the peyote you turn into
different animals you could show someone
a screenshot of maneater and say that
it's probably cheats here okay I've
changed the thing hopefully it does it
yeah that's a good title
it's a good Friday not bad sure we have
a lot of issues with yeah well rough
going up first but you know everything's
a-okay everything's fine now yeah eat
that shark you're an elder sure I am
it's trying to like assess where you are
in comparison to where I am because I'm
in the same zone I'm just gonna keep
going on these guys for a hot minute
although I need to actually yeah I do
like that just getting away and doing
like hit-and-run stuff works really well
yeah the game is very flexible like that
I need some fish to
what our favorite games to play this
year uh this is the year that I
discovered that I'm actually in a JRPGs
so it's a lot of like Final Fantasy 7
might be the best game I played this
year so far la 15 7 remains it's about
the original you're also dreaming hey
yeah I'm place right now Dragon Quest
really good finished that earlier yeah
or before we all go hey if you if you're
specifically talking games that came out
this year I would say remake half-life
alex has been great doom eternals been
really good maneater surprisingly good
time I mean yeah I'm pretty sure
man-eaters gonna be like probably in
like my top 5 unless something crazy
happens this year and there's no way I
can fit it in imagine you're just
hanging out on a boardwalk and then this
[ __ ] shark starts eating everybody
not just this shark but the shark
covered in stone shards yeah and just
360 noscopes spinning on people also for
anyone who played tripwires other game
killing floor I think this game is tied
to it and I intend to prove it
eventually I look forward to your my
long photo feature yeah oh
unable to get some putts oh man you
realize how much uh how much up you can
get oh yeah you can have you've been
trying to get always and say like the
license plates that are up high they
teach you how to do the jumps just right
oh I didn't I - you can technical you
jump like three times and then you also
get a jump boost when you lock on with
so if you make sure that your you're
looking at it when you jump you'll
actually lock onto it and it'll cause
you to get that little extra rest okay
another thing too is if you have the
bioelectric body the EMP actually grabs
stuff around you interesting okay yeah
got it
hey I'll see that guy
can you be megalodon in manire hello
I hope so it'd be it'd be a wild time
eating boats whole it wouldn't make any
sense because you're a bull shark you
would literally be turning into a
different like species but sure why not
I'd be ideal for it again just to give
you like a little bit of like a a
preview of I could I don't if you Jim
play much killing for I didn't know see
it you probably haven't noticed them
like talking about some of the stuff but
just as a big hint like if you look off
at the the skyline mm-hmm were they all
the bill or literally like the building
where they made like all the zombies and
killing floors right there with the H on
it oh and also the toy store is there
that exists in the Canon but yeah so
you're you're basically swimming around
in the toxic runoff from the facility
that made all of the zombie things in
killing Oh excellent which may be why
you're mutating and changing well you
know just looking horrifying yeah
how many hours are ticking it gets your
level how long have you played oh it's a
good question I'm not uh I'm not sure
what my my hour count is so I I got to
the top level in like 20 hours
okay I've definitely not put in 20 hours
but you've also been doing all the side
stuff I've only been doing enough to
progress for the story and then just
moving it forward sorry I'm I'm I'm at
the spot you are but I've already been
max level for a while yeah yeah I like
just hit this like the other night
mutating into a three-yard sharks wing
and factory waste that's how it works
that's how it be to Megalodon DLC would
be really cool I also really like this
is Stephanie worth kind of shouting out
the different zones that you do stuff in
yeah well very different I should I
should I go to a different area if you
want I like the one that's after this
too cuz it's it's like a bigger open
water area and their cruise liners and
the whole like theme park yeah yeah yeah
it's cool I'll go I'll head over in that
direction it's cool that would I rate
this game out of 10 I'm not a reviewer
but if you do want to see like our
official review we have it up me
personally I and my my opinion isn't
like a like an official thing for
GameSpot at all but I probably say like
I'm like an 8 on it yeah like a good
strong eight
like it's it's not perfect it's not it's
not gonna revolutionize anything but
it's really good at what it does and
then it does more than what I expected
mm-hmm I would agree it was a game that
honestly when I first started I was like
I I don't know if I'll play much of this
I don't know if I'm feeling it
but I gave it I gave it a shot you were
you were telling me how much you were
enjoying it and I was like you know what
maybe I'll give it more time and then I
ended up really really liking it so I'm
glad I was able to kind of swim yeah
that'd be is really like oh no I just
swim around and bite stuff and then get
chased away and combats really yeah I
would say if you're not feeling it at
the beginning give it a little bit of
time is my recommendation at least get
yeah Elite it to be a team get to get to
like the second area really it's like
once I hit the third area is when I was
like okay we're in it now yeah just eat
that guy yeah
you gotta love we're having people off
of the front of their ships just midair
right Watts know what gameís is this is
maneater it just came out today on ps4
Xbox one and PC and we're checking it
out
because we were originally playing GTA 5
and it broke I also want to say we all
almost doubled the number of people who
were in here ever since we switched to
be inator oh heck yeah I'll take it
though yeah so sharks bring everyone to
yard it's for your pina hey I'm I'm
happy to share it with you guys it's the
least I could do like I said I've played
20 hours and I think it's it's a really
good game and I feel like a lot of
people might overlook it cuz I you look
at it you're like a shark game but why
would I even worry about oh hello
can you still see the screen by the way
is it still good for you yeah okay just
it's it's a bit it's a bit laggy bonus
it's not okay that's good yeah yeah I
would say like I mean you know the
game's not perfect it I think the
missions are very repetitive the combat
is doesn't have as much depth as I'd
want it to be but I don't know man what
you're doing [ __ ] like this it's a good
time how can you like you be upset at
that it's really dumb I mean I know how
people could be upset I understand but
how can you be upset at you have to go
to work have a good stream enjoy oh for
sure thanks for stopping by read
appreciate it god that you could stop by
even for a bit
heck yeah the cats are back to trying to
bust down my door feel bad even let him
in yeah he's been like real like I don't
know what it is he's like in a mood
today where he's lots of tension and
he's rude about it so I locked him out I
can hang out with his mom I had to get
back in the water because I was about to
drowned set in here any update once you
see so it's out on pc it's on the epic
game store I'm not sure about steam so
uh my time fixed yeah I would I would by
the way I would recommend hopefully the
iron in out but it sounds like both the
console versions did have some issues
the ps4 was having some frame hitching
stuff right yes what uh everything was
going on
yeah reviewer Phil horn shock gave who
gave the game at 7 p.m. for version was
having some issues yours also had a
weird issue where he did your xbox yes
so I I put a full stone build fully
leveled up on and I fought like six
boats at once and just trashed a whole
bunch in my phone or my my fans started
like there
like take off and then the Xbox just
shut down and it told me that I need to
ventilate it better yeah so the game
might have a couple issues on consoles
pc which is what i'm playing right now
has been super smooth i haven't had any
issues so if you are thinking about
picking it up i would recommend the pc
version if you can because it seems to
Jack and also smooth this version it's
it's thirty bucks instead of 40 yeah we
get the free coupon and I would say
thirty is a great price for this game
like thirty is a steal thirty 30 is a
really good price you know I'm I'm not
one to normally try to equate like
quality or like you know like time and
quality to price or whatever but I would
say like the the type of game this is
like that kind of mid tier game thirty
feels like the perfect price for a game
like this okay let's see it's good some
people game so I should give a ten to
last os2 or I'll be hunting you down I
haven't played it so know if it's gonna
be a ten but also why would she haunt
someone down for not giving a game a
perfect score that's silly yeah that's
weird
don't do that yeah I highly recommend
not hunting people down if they don't
give the game a ten because what if ya
don't be that what if I told you I told
you I thought the Last of Us one was in
the ten whatever told you thought
laughter this one wasn't even in nine
wow that's just me dance me damn uh I
enjoyed the Last of Us one it just I
feel like it wasn't as big a deal as
long right but that's fine it's
definitely a respectful in a lot of
people there are a fair amount of people
who feel that way then we're not all not
also I'm great I'm a big dumb idiot
you're just loves Metal Gear and visual
novels so like what do I know
hey man that's a valid opinion
I'm well check these messages yeah we're
about time anyway we're we're about
running up on time here that's true so
[Music]
uh yeah well let's see these people here
let's finish eating these people that
will call it a stream it's all good
I just like to poke fun a bit you know
what seriously
don't threaten to come after people if
they don't give games yeah you have
you're kidding man that's fine it's just
unfortunately in our line of work there
are plenty of people who say that to us
that are not kidding
it you get a lot which is unfortunate
but I'm glad to hear that you're not one
of them yes it's it's good we're glad to
hear you're not wrong and alright one
more back the office wind I have no idea
yeah no idea to be honest I'm not I'm
not as as much as quarantine is driving
me a little stir-crazy I'm not in a rush
to put myself in a situation where I
could you know get sick or get other
people sick so I am more than happy to
take the time I need to know that things
are gonna be good I'm down to play it
safe we haven't even really talked about
it much I know a lot of other places
kind of the same a similar policy to
we're all just kind of reading am
alright
I hate all those people Ben you had me
at anything Richard shark dude this is
the title change was well I'm glad I was
able to help you guys out but
unfortunately that is where we have to
call it I would I would happily do more
maneater like I would I would have just
said screw it and just keep going but
unfortunately it's real busy today Ben
you're getting messages popping off I
know I got a thing I got to take care of
there's their copy going since GCA
wouldn't load but yeah you know what
that is dope all right there we go yeah
that is maneater but game we definitely
started this stream streaming and I've
been streaming the whole time man either
if you want to either play through let
let everyone know comment tell tell
people what man eater rich yeah alright
well thank you guys for hanging out with
us
apologies for those of you who came in
hoping to play GTA with us unfortunately
it was just not happening rockstar
servers have been all out of whack
probably because everyone's been trying
to hop onto that game because of it
being free for the last week on epic but
I think we're gonna try to we're
definitely gonna try it again at some
point maybe next week but we might also
do mortal kombat next week because that
is something that a lot of people like
to play with us and they got that big
update happening so we might do that but
either way I hope you guys will come
back and check it out me and Ben stream
on Friday right now we're doing 11 I
think we'll stick with that for a little
bit see if that works better than 2 for
us and yeah anything else do you want to
say Ben don't be a fool stay in school
play danganronpa playoff as a play
maneater play maneater do this game is
great play it yeah highly recommend and
thank you so much for hanging out with
us and I hope you have a wonderful long
weekend if you have it or just a great
weekend if ya enjoy that Memorial Day
everybody
[Music]
[Music]